[Music]
why do you suppose i just hurled a chair
at your head neiman
i i don't know sure you do the tempo
were you rushing or were you dragging
i i don't know
start counting five six seven four damn
it look at me
one two three four one two three four
one
two three no was i rushing or was i
dragging
oh no count again one two three
one two three four one two three rushing
or dragging rushing so you do know the
difference
if you deliberately sabotage my band i
will
[ __ ] you like a pig now are you a rusher
or are you a dragger or are you gonna be
on my
[ __ ] time i'm gonna be on your time
what does that say quarter note equals
215. count me at 215.
a one two three four one two three four
jesus [ __ ] christ
i didn't know they allowed retards into
shaffer am i to understand that you
cannot read tempo
can you even [ __ ] read music what is
that eighth note yes what is that
doubted sixteenth note sight read
measure 101
but you're a group play the goddamn
kit now answer my question
were you rushing or were you dragging
answer russian
oh my dear god are you one of those
single-tier
people do i look like a double [ __ ]
rainbow to you
you must be upset are you upset no
no so you just don't give a [ __ ] about
any of this i do give a [ __ ] about this
are you
upset yes or [ __ ] no yes you
are upset yeah say it
i'm upset say it so the whole band can
hear you
i'm upset louder
i'm upset louder i'm upset
you are a worthless friendless [ __ ]
lip little piece of [ __ ] whose mommy
left daddy when she figured out he
wasn't eugene o'neill
and it was now weeping and slobbering
all over my drum set like a [ __ ]
nine-year-old girl
so for the final father [ __ ] time
say it louder i'm upset carl
start practicing harder neiman
whiplash bar 125
big boy tempo five six and
[Music]